new details emerged about the brad pitt  angelina jolie's split and the  negotiations happening behind the scenes  a source close to the child custody  dispute tells ET quote there have been  productive discussions they add quote  the fact that things have quieted down  is a good sign for everyone our source  told us Wednesday Brad voluntarily took  a drug test as a preemptive strike in  the custody battle process that source  also says Pitt remains in LA and it's  unclear when you will see his children  again et has confirmed that right now  Angelina and the kids are in seclusion  at a 12 million dollar rented home in  Malibu meanwhile Brad pulled out of  Wednesday night's premiere of voyage of  time a documentary he narrated